-You've been honest
about a couple things.
One, you have endorsed
Bernie Sanders.
-Yes.
-And, two, you have encouraged
all Democrats to do the same
which is, whoever the nomine
is, you will support.
-Absolutely. Yes, yes.
-And --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-In fact, I just --
I thought, all of us --
We are coming.
Trump. Where is Trump?
Which one is he?
-He usually watches
on that camera, yeah.
-Okay. We, on November 3rd
are coming.
And we are large.
Our army --
[ Cheers and applause ]
It doesn't matter.
I mean, seriously, he --
They had a poll last month
A literal, actual poll.
"Who would you vote for --
Trump or the Roomba?"
The robot vacuum.
-Yeah, sure.
-And the Roomba won.
-The Roomba won?
-The Roomba won.
-Wow.
-So he's in deep trouble.
-I want to talk to you about
where you're at as far as
optimism versus pessimism.
But, first,
I wanted to get your take
on when we talk about
endorsements --
"The New York Times"
endorsed Elizabeth Warren
and Amy Klobuchar yesterday.
-I watched that.
-Yeah, what are you -- Right
It was on their televised show
They have a TV show,
"The New York Times."
-They have a TV show on FX..
-Yeah.
-...called "The weekly."
-"The Weekly," yes.
-And I don't know
why I'm giving it a plug,
because now I'm just going t
say something awful.
-Oh, you're gonna now --
You're gonna unplug it.
-Well, I just --
I turned it on last night.
-Uh-huh.
-And it's -- I thought
"The Apprentice" was back.
Because they literally
brought each of
the Democratic candidates
into a big board room.
-Mm-hmm.
-Where they have them sit
at the table and do, like,
a dog-and-pony show
for the editorial board
of "The New York Times."
I don't know why I did
"editorial board."
Because I, frankly, wish
I had never seen -- Don't you --
when you think of the editoria
board of "The New York Times,"
you think it's like whole
bunches of brainiac people
-Sure. Yes.
It's a very esteemed newspaper
-You want them
to be smarter than you.
And then they go on FX.
And you see
what the process is like,
and you see them,
and they're like,
"Oh, they're just like,
well, like The Band."
-Hey. Don't you --
-No.
[ Audience groans ]
-No, but -- No, no. No!
We would live in a better
country if The Band could pick
and the endorsement of the nex
President of the United States
But it just kind of
blew my mind that --
-They seem very human.
-Okay. Well, that's fine.
I mean, they are human beings.
-No, but we need all the hel
we can get right now.
-Yeah.
-And we don't need them --
They started asking question
of the candidates like,
"When was the --
Who's the person that
broke your heart the most?
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-"Who's the person that
broke your heart the..."
We're in deep [bleep] right now!
-Yeah, that's --
-Why are you asking
these questions?!
You know? Aren't you afrai
of Mitch McConnell?
You know, it's like you're not
going to get any laws passed
It was just -- I don't know.
It's just --
-You didn't care for it.
-I didn't care for it.
-You do -- You do have --
You do have --
Even though you would say
we're in deep [bleep],
you do have some optimism
right now.
-I have optimism. I'll tell you.
I said after the 2016 -- The
endorsed Klobuchar and Warren.
But I said after the '16
election, because nobody -
I kept saying Hillary
got the most votes.
We need to keep this in mind
Do not despair.
The majority of country thinks
like we do by 3 million votes.
And what we should do actually
in 2020, we shouldn't --
We shouldn't run one woman
We should run two women.
The ticket -- the vice president
and president on the ticke
will be two women.
Let's just double down on this
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's just double down and -
You know?
And all the pundits will go,
"Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, you can't do that.
They'll never get elected now.
And like, "Oh, yeah?"
I'll tell you right now.
Every woman's gonna vote."
And every young person's
gonna vote.
And anybody -- anybody
who's part of any group
that has had the boot on their
neck for most of their lives
because they belong to
a particular ethnic group,
a particular gender,
a particular age group --
Everybody who knows that feeling
will come out and be for that.
And it's so amazing to me that
the youngest in all the polls,
the youngest voters, 18 to 35,
by a vast margin,
are for the oldest candidate
that's running.
-Yeah.
-That's so amazing
that our young people --
Because they know
it's their future that we're
really voting on this year
This is -- If we don't fix
climate change, like, now,
we don't have four years.
-Right.
-We're done. We're done.
We're done.
And so what they love --
what they love about --
What they love about Berni
is that he's fighting
for their future.
He will not relent.
They know he can't be bought
He will not give in.
And it's not his future
he's fighting for.
He won't be around to see what's
going to happen to this planet
This is totally selfless
on his part
that he is going to give
his last years of his life
He's in the last quarter o
his life. Can we say that?
It's not -- -
-I think -- Well, what is he
76?
-No, no. He's 78.
-78. Yeah, yeah. He's in the
last quarter of his life.
-He's in the last quarter
of his life. I'm just saying
-That's a perfectly
fine thing to say.
-And I hope he's not
watching right now
and then, you know, he's like...
-Oh, no, I -- And, by the way,
like, you know, you're sayin
you really want him
to have the greatest quarter
of his life, maybe.
-It's going to be
the best quarter.
-Yeah.
-It's going to be -- Whatever.
What did Kansas City --
They're gonna come back.
It's going to be amazing.
-Yeah.
-And I'm telling you that Bernie
is going to get in there.
He's the one candidate Trump
doesn't want to run against.
He's the Trump stopper.
-Well, that's interesting
'cause Donald Trump keeps
speaking very highly of Bernie
-Yes.
-And in order to think he want
to run against Bernie,
that would require you to thin
that he's playing sort of a --
People always say about Trum
"3D chess,"
which I don't think is the case.
-Yeah, that -- Ohh.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-That requires way too much.
-So you --
I mean, on a very surface level,
you can assume
that his praise for Bernie
is a way for him --
-He doesn't want to run ag--
He's afraid of him.
-Gotcha.
-Remember, the bully, whic
Trump was and always has been.
The bully is always afraid
of that which will
bring the bully down.
In other words,
the kid on the school yard
who's going to stand up
to the bully.
That's the bully's last da
of bullying anybody.
And that is Bernie Sanders
He will not relent.
He will not back down.
And -- And he will
take care of Trump
in such a beautiful
Brooklyn-like way.
I want to -- I want to --
-Brooklyn v. Queens.
Really.
-It's Brooklyn versus Queens
and with all due respect t
the fine borough of Queens
advantage Brooklyn.